[Aplausos]
hay dos días importantes en la vida el
día que naces y el día que sabes para
que naces cuando encuentras ese
propósito hay dos días importantes en su
vida el día que nace y el día que saben
para qué nace soy camila cooper esposa
mujer mamá emprendedora social
convencida de que desde nuestro rol
podemos transformar el mundo así que hoy
les voy a contar cómo encontré yo ese
propósito y quiero transpirar lo para
ustedes a través del libro de mi vida
introducción la vida perfecta que nos
dicen que debemos estudiar
sacar muy buenas calificaciones
prepararnos salir al mundo laboral
encontrar al esposo perfecto crear una
familia y ese debe ser el ciclo de la
vida perfecta capítulo 1 mi primer
fracaso muchas veces no estamos
preparados para esa palabra fracasar
este corto caminar me ha enseñado que es
la oportunidad de conocernos y darnos
cuenta de que somos capaces pero nos han
vendido el fracaso con esa relación de
miedo o de frustración y es lo contrario
es una oportunidad así que mi primer
fracaso fue bastante difícil sentía que
mi mundo se derrumba capítulo 2 y
vivieron felices para siempre me casé
era supuestamente feliz en otro país
como muchas veces nos venden la idea de
que estar afuera es mejor o si nos
casamos con una persona afuera es mejor
capítulo 3 el dinero no compra la
felicidad muchas veces
delegamos esa esencia de ser felices ese
propósito de estar acá en el tener
queremos tener más queremos tener más
títulos queremos tener más bienes
materiales
queremos tener tener y tener capítulo 4
no sé quién soy cuando ya no somos
capaces de luchar por nuestro propósito
de vida por lo que nos hace felices y
este tener nos abruma y se apropia de
nuestros propios sueños y nuestros
propios ideales la mente es muy sabia y
es muy poderosa y es cuando ella decide
si tú no eres capaz yo soy capaz y
parece que no
estuve internada en un hospital
psiquiátrico en londres casi 10 días
no sabía ni quién era ni sabía quién
estaba al lado mío y precisamente esta
situación fue la que me demostró que
somos capaces de todo lo que queramos yo
salí de ahí aquí me ven puedan estar
bien les prometo que estoy bien capítulo
5 y la vida nos vuelve a dar
oportunidades cuando no pasamos ese
punto de no retorno es cuando podemos
volver a empezar y volví a colombia y
volvía a mi tierra volví con mi gente y
volví a sentir que era lo que me
motivaba a estar viva tuve otra
oportunidad capítulo 6 lo llamó el
capítulo de rediseñarse entonces cambié
el tener y el hacer y priorizó él
yo iba a trabajar desde mí desde camila
como una persona feliz porque se había
sido siempre mi propósito de vida e iba
a rediseñar todo mi entorno a través de
eso holísticamente a partir de mi iba a
construir lo que yo soñaba lo que yo
quería capítulo 7 el amor llegó pero si
yo estaba segura de lo que yo era el
amor que iba a llegar a mi vida era el
que yo merecía mi esposo mi compañero mi
coequipero mi constructor de sueños y
luego gabriel vino a este mundo para
elegirme como su mamá y me dio el mejor
superpoder de todos los miedos los
deseos que yo tenía de trabajar desde la
labor social desde el servicio desde el
3 entregarme a otros el vino a este
mundo
darme el poder de dar el paso y hacerlo
muchas veces queremos y queremos hacer
muchas cosas pero nos da miedo nos dan
muchos temores pero gabriel cambió toda
mi arquitectura cerebral cierto porque
físicamente nos estamos transformando
para decirme tú puedes confía en ti tú
eres capaz y nace un propósito por ellas
por las mamás por la mamá que yo fui iba
a dedicar todos los días de mi vida
desde que me levantaba hasta que me
acostaba fuera lunes fuera domingo fuera
sábado iba a dividir por un propósito
que se llama transformar la sociedad
desde que nacemos era decirle a las
mamás que tienen un poder infinito en
sus hijos si los educan con amor y con
ejemplo no necesitamos más para
transformar este país en donde estamos y
desde ahí yo quería construir mi
propósito de vida
desde gabriel dar ejemplo de servicio
con él a mi lado como una esperanza y
como un ejemplo de que sí se podía
capítulo 10 los miedos son el pan de
cada día cada día desde que nos
levantamos hasta que nos acostamos nos
preguntamos y cómo lo vamos a hacer y
tengo miedo de fracasar y tengo miedo de
no poder y tengo miedo del qué dirán y
la única forma de poder derrumbar esos
miedos es mirándolos agarrando los de
frente y arriesgarse hay que dar el
salto y ese es el capítulo se llaman
riesgos es hacer esas movidas en tu vida
que te sacan de la zona de confort que
te enseñan y te muestran que estás vivo
porque cuando nos salimos de esa forma
de esa zona de confort nos rediseñamos y
cuando tenemos un propósito ese rediseño
es enriquecedor y nos motiva a hacer
nuestra mejor versión
capítulo 12 es lo más lindo de todo
hablar motivarnos prepararnos para
cumplir nuestros sueños y lo más
importante son los resultados
esos resultados que nos demuestran que
sí podemos que nos valida nuestro día a
día es ir a donde esas mamás es hacer el
trabajo que nosotros hacemos y proteger
y transformar la vida de cada niño que
nace en colombia nos va a inspirar un
poco
[Música]
y es el capítulo 13 lo llame milagros
porque cuando te alineas con tu ser
cuando cumples tus sueños y tu propósito
el universo se alinea contigo y sucede
en los verdaderos milagros se acuerdan
el paro de avianca y todo lo que sucedía
en los aeropuertos de colombia pues
nosotros tuvimos la dicha de estar en
ese paro y sentarnos en un avión con la
persona con la que habíamos planeado
sentarnos hacía seis meses y no lo
lográbamos porque no logramos porque
estábamos trabajando por un propósito y
hoy en día existe cunas con amor para
las mujeres privadas de la libertad en
toda colombia soñar se puede y el
universo les ayuda simplemente se trata
de saber pedirle al universo y estar
alineado con el mis dos días importantes
en la vida el día que nací 11 de junio
de 1986 y el día que nació mi fundación
primero de noviembre del 2016 el día que
encontré un propósito de vida para
terminar les quería preguntar que ven
acá
una plastilina verde y si yo les dijera
que yo veo la oportunidad de transformar
el mundo y tenerlo en mis manos
así hoy ustedes me digan que no que ven
una plastilina verde si yo estoy
convencida de lo que estoy viendo sin
ser terca y decir que es una plastilina
azul voy a poder el día de mañana
transformar el mundo y cuando lo haga
ustedes van a estar conmigo persigan sus
utopías vivan el día ideal que quieran
vivir para que cuando se levanten sean
felices
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]